hey 42 here you think with a reality TV
star as president a playboy as Prime
Minister an ex-kgb agent as czar and a
man addicted to Emmental cheese as
supreme leader we were entering the peak
of bizarre rulers returns a strange
rulers have been a fixture for about as
long as we've had one in charge of all
the bizarre and deranged monarchs in
history Vlad the Impaler is perhaps
unique amongst them all for the
staggering absurdity of his sadism and
lust for murder so absurd that he was
the direct influence for Bram Stoker's
Count Dracula when your legacy is being
the basis for one of the most evil
characters in fiction you know you're a
dick
Vlad had an interesting life he was 15th
century voivode ruler of villagio
modern-day sovereign Romania
three times and maybe the most brutal
man who ever lived he was a member of
the order of the Dragon
a group of multicultural noblemen who
banded together to repel the Ottomans
and fight for Christianity the order
gave him the sobriquet drakul or dracula
in this endeavor he fared poorly because
early on in his life he was captured by
the Ottomans and kept prisoner in an
attempt to blackmail his father below
capture sounds bad he was relatively
well treated being given training in
horseback riding
fighting science and the arts as to why
you take someone hostage and train them
how to kill you is beyond me but that's
quite literally what happened eventually
Vlad's brother who had also been
captured changed allegiance to the
Turkish side but not flat Vlad had a big
impaling based future awaiting him he
hung on to his anger and being captured
and never lost his animosity towards the
Turks soon Vlad was released and he
almost immediately set about attempting
to
he gained his father's fro he was
murdered during Vlad's absence Vlad
succeeded then lost it again then
regained it once more cutting ties with
the Ottomans at the process but as he
would have mentioned acquiring the frame
requires one to silence critics and
consolidate power and Vlad as destiny
would have it at the perfect technique
to do just that he would impale as many
people as humanly possible impaling if
you don't know is where a giant spike is
rammed so far up your ass that it comes
out of your mouth sometimes you are only
partially impaled at the start letting
gravity slowly move to spike upwards and
through you as you move downwards it's a
technique that truly brings new meaning
to the phrase a pain in the ass I'll let
you try and think of a worse death Vlad
bloody loved impaling people he must
have after all he did it so much he was
named after it he murdered all those who
challenged his authority and had their
still twitching bodies impaled on spikes
he was said to have impaled two monks
and when their morning donkey refused to
stop braying had the poor thing impaled
as well
a group of Turkish and Voice refused to
remove their turbans due to religious
custom so Vlad nailed their turbans to
their skulls and you guessed it impaled
them as he did with many of our
dignitaries and prisoners under his
command just what was his problem
exactly nobody really knows he was said
to have impaled 20 3844 turkish corpses
during the invasion of bulgaria
creating a veritable forest of impaled
bodies think about that
over 20,000 corpses with spikes up their
backsides if he were around today
romanian defense minister Ione husky
said he would have been condemned for
crimes against humanity if he were tried
at Nuremberg but I think that's rather
self-evident to be fair history is
littered with bizarre rulers it doesn't
matter which part of the world you go to
it seems that strange people have a
knack for acquiring power as to whether
it's the power that makes them strange
or the fact that strange people are
drawn towards power isn't clear but what
is clear is that the list of them is
practically endless Charles's 6/4 he was
made out of glass and would have
seizures so violence he killed his
companions and with EF had people kiss
his bed linen to make sure it wasn't
poisoned the Spanish royal family shared
their beds of the body parts of st.
George the fourth residents who kill
himself if women didn't sleep with him
Nebuchadnezzar had a biblical descent
into madness Peter the Great was
obsessed with holding enormous weddings
for Dwarfs kin chuang who drank mercury
in the pursuit of immortality spoiler it
didn't work now as far as Roman emperors
go you know you're a madman when you
exceed the lunacy of Nero who famously
played the fiddle whilst watching Rome
burn and there was only one Emperor who
managed that impressive feat Caligula a
man so not there was even an erotic
historical movie made about him in 1979
that had completely unstimulated sex
scenes which is a highbrow way of saying
porn Caligula ruled the Roman Empire
during the years 37 to 41 ad a short
reign but one that left an indelible
impression on
the son of a great military leader
Caligula wound up under the wing of none
other than Roman emperor Tiberius who
was a psychopathic child molester who
enjoyed watching his enemies being
thrown off cliffs when that's your role
model how can you not grow up mentally
deranged sure enough a young Caligula
was already an adept manipulated with a
punch on four maliciousness and getting
his way one overseer said of him never
was there a better servant of a worse
master but this isn't to say Caligula
was in complete mastery of himself in
fact he was often at the mercy of his
own passions colliculus lames who have
planned to kill the Emperor even
venturing into his bedroom with a dagger
to kill him before changing his mind
this was in revenge for the way Tiberius
had treated his mother Agra Pina the
elder but perhaps it was the Emperor
himself who had his own plans for young
Caligula Suetonius the Roman historian
who penned the vita Caesar the twelve
Caesars from whom we know most of what
we know about Caligula's history
postulated that Tiberius looked after
Caligula with the sole desire of as he
set himself rearing a viper for the
Roman people and taking someone who was
already cruel and vicious and turning
him into something far worse in
Suetonius his words the ruin of himself
and of all men in this he certainly
succeeded Caligula was to put it
politely a madman Nero was an evil man
sure but he knew he was evil he was sane
and very self-aware Caligula however was
evil and mentally unhinged which is
arguably more dangerous
although adored by the Roman people when
he first inherited the title of Emperor
from Tiberius it wasn't long before this
changed
after a period of sickness the power of
the title went swiftly to Caligula's
head and
soon his insatiable appetite for
eccentric cruelty became apparent to all
amongst his many actions he ordered his
army to plunder the sea by collecting
shells in their helmets requisitioned
countless Roman ships so that he could
have them fashioned into a two-mile long
bridge for his horse rides the resulting
shortage of ships caused a Roman people
to staff falsely accused killed and
imprisoned people in order to steal
their estates bans the mention of goats
in his presence as he was insecure about
his tall hairy appearance auctioned the
Liars of gladiators it shows spent 2.7
billion sesterces in his first year in
office a huge sum even by modern
standards tormented senators by making
them run for miles in front of his
speeding chariot drank pearls dissolved
in vinegar dressed in wicks shoes and
women's clothes in attempts to appear
like anyone other than himself gave his
horse an entire house of its own and
even attempted to give it a role in
government though the historicity of
this one has been argued against had
countless affairs with his allied wives
had possible incestuous affairs with his
sister loved to use the phrase remember
that I have the right to do anything to
any body and to cap it off he pretended
he was a gut his excesses became so
great that the praetorian guard the
Senate and the Equestrian Order got
together and decided to ambush and kill
him he is now remembered in history as
the first Roman Emperor to be
assassinated but not the last Caligula
wasn't the only ruler to get lost in his
own childish and insane in
horses if we leave ancient Rome
fast-forward 1750 years and take
ourselves into the sprawling expanse of
Russia we find another rule a unique in
his weirdness czar Paula first 1796 -
1801 little explanation at Zappos
insanity is needed as much as a glance
at his portrait will suffice just look
at that forehead no seriously look at it
but for the sake of this video I'll do
my best in order to understand Paul you
have to understand that he really really
really loved his chivalric stories those
being stories about Knights honor saving
maidens quests and all the nonsense so
famously lampooned by Miguel de
Cervantes in Don Quixote Paul loved
these stories so much they consumed his
life he was obsessed with the exact
details of his soldiers uniforms taking
loans to ensure that they were
excruciating ly elaborate and in perfect
order like a perfect night around anyone
who didn't meet saw Paul's fantastical
standards would find themselves on the
wrong end of a flogging which Paul
sometimes carried out himself savagely
whipping his victims for failing to
appear in tidy jackets
Paul was no stranger to ordering full
dress parades right in front of his
palace even if it was knee-deep finger
freezing Russian winter he had erratic
changes of minds which unsettles the
various foreign powers around the world
one example of this was when he decided
that a full regiment of soldiers should
march on foot all the way to Siberia a
casual couple of thousand mile warned
luckily for them he suddenly changed his
mind and told them to turn back as part
of his love of chivalry czar Paul became
completely enchanted by the order of st.
John a real-life religious order of
chivalric Knights he eventually gains
their attention became a grandmaster
which irritated the Pope and almost went
to war with France and England when he
felt the order's dignity had been
besmirched he considered the Russian
nobility around him to be a pack of
untrustworthy scoundrels unworthy of his
chivalry ambitions as a result he
attempted to groom them into the fine
respectable honourable members of a
modern-day chivalric order to those who
listened he gave lumps and titles to
those who did not he took them away
needless to say if you are even remotely
familiar of Russian history you can
probably guess how this turned out Paul
became unbelievably paranoid that
everyone was sick of him and planning to
kill him and it turns out they were upon
hearing men sneaking towards his bedroom
at night he attempted to hide behind the
drapes unfortunately his curtains were
not a portal to another dimension and
they found him he was brutally garroted
to death with a silk scarf which is a
totally embarrassing way to go for a guy
obsessed with heroism but you needn't
look even that far into the past you
find complete lunatics at the Helms of
Nations in fact you only have to look
back as far as 1936 when King Farouk the
first world Egypt
let's run through a quick checklist
owned thousands of bespoke suits check
hoarded cars jewels and watches check
was obsessed with women and sex check
[ __ ] check owned an autographed photo
avid of Hitler as you do check bloated
and overweight check cartoon villain
mustache check rocked a cracking fairs
check as you can see King Farouk had it
all and buy it all I mean all the
ingredients necessary to make for a very
strange reign on top of all this King
Farouk had one defining characteristic
he was a complete and otter man child he
would hurl food at dignitaries and cheer
when he hit them even during formal
state-sponsored meals
he gave a man the position Minister of
Justice because he had a great mustache
a wise decision if you ask me he slid
ice cubes down woman's exposed cleavages
and told them to cool off he collected
everything from medieval suits of armor
to Faberge eggs to ancient Tibetan coins
because why the hell not he even drove
around honking his special custom-made
car horn that he purpose-built to sound
like a dog being killed but it doesn't
stop there he once had a nightmare
involving lions and upon waking promptly
went to Cairo Zoo and blew two of them
away in revenge
when he began to dislike a train station
he used a few times per year he helped
the whole thing torn down and then
rebuilt it as an absurd cost he even
most bizarrely was an adept pickpocket
having being trained by a professional
thief he was so adept that he managed to
deprive Juan Winston Churchill of his
watch when the theft was discovered for
root threw up his hands smiled and
declared that he'd found it right where
he was sitting what a coincidence
widely condemned to be corrupt and
ineffectual Farouk behavior led him to
be overthrown forced into exile and his
possessions which included one of the
largest collections of pornography in
the world became this subject of
national ridicule now Trump's tweets
maybe a tad bizarre at times but at
least he doesn't walk around in affairs
shooting Lions thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me on patreon which
really helps me to continue to make them
you can find a link in a description
below also you can get your hands on a
first edition signed copy of my new book
stick a flag in it by heading on over to
unbound publishing the links in the
description and pre-ordering your copy
today thank you